well the breaking news at this hour is
that rush limbaugh
an iconic figure in the conservative
movement and the creator really of an
alternative media
altogether uh he has passed away of lung
cancer at the age of 70.
according to ryan svedra writing for the
daily wire conservative radio icon rush
limbaugh passed away on wednesday
morning at 70 years old following his
year-long battle with lung cancer
we the limbaugh family are deeply
saddened to announce that our beloved
rush has died limbaugh's wife catherine
adams limbaugh said in a post on her
husband's facebook account
rush hudson lib limbaugh iii will
forever be the greatest of all time a
courageous brilliant gentle giant and
radio pioneer
our entire family is so thankful to
everyone who prayed and cared for russia
especially the audience he adored
russia's love for our country and for
all of you we'll live on
eternally rush of course had been
expecting something very much like this
over the past few months
he said in his final radio broadcast of
2020 i wasn't expected to be alive today
i wasn't expected to make it to october
and then to november and then to
december
and here i am today got some problems
feeling pretty good president trump
awarded
rush the presidential medal of freedom
at the 2020 state of the union
following limbaugh's revealing to the
world that he had been diagnosed with
cancer
at the time president trump said almost
every american family knows the pain
when a loved one is diagnosed with a
serious illness
here tonight is a special man beloved by
millions of americans who just received
a stage four advanced cancer diagnosis
this is not good news what is good news
is that he is the greatest fighter and
winner you will ever meet rush limbaugh
thank you for your decades of tireless
devotion to our country
producer james goldman who's known as
boasts nerdly on air
he wrote on twitter last week our
prayers are with russia as he continues
to fight the illness
he has been afflicted with we are still
praying for a remission
back in december obviously limbo opened
up about the cancer diagnosis saying
that people should take time to be
thankful for life because everybody has
an expiration
date russia is a seminal figure in the
history of american conservatism
the most prominent conservative in
america following william f buckley
the fact is that russ shaped millions of
us i grew up listening to rush
so did virtually every conservative of
my age group i remember riding to
college
in my 1986 honda civic with no air
conditioning listening to rush
on the way there i remember being in the
car with my dad and turning on rush
limbaugh and listening to what rush had
to say
on the day's event rush almost literally
created
the entire alternative media
infrastructure by creating talk radio
the rush limbaugh show debuted on august
1st in 1988
on a handful of am radio stations across
the country according to fox news
in the more than 30 years since there
have been many memorable moments and a
few long-running gags that helped make
the show and it's so popular among a
wide swath of the population
rush obviously was famous for saying
that he had talent online from god now
the talent has been returned
to his creator rush was very
tongue-in-cheek his show was
insightful and funny the left hated
hated it because the left hates all
conservatives who have any level of
prominence
they are spending today celebrating you
can tell the disgustingness of
the left today by how they are reacting
to russia limbaugh's death not with any
level of class
not even with any level of of
remove instead they're just jumping
right in
ecstatic about the fact that a man died
at the age of 70
of lung cancer because they disagreed
with rush limbaugh politically now
i didn't know rush particularly well i
met russia on a couple of occasions when
i met him he was unfailingly polite
i would say shockingly almost shy
in in private uh rush limbaugh was was a
uh
he was a private guy he was not somebody
who was boisterous and loud
he was unflinchingly generous to pretty
much everybody who knew him well
i'm close with david limbaugh russia's
brother david is a credit to his family
russia obviously was as well rushed gave
so many members
of the movement their start in radio and
in politics
from mark levin to sean hannity to
michael medved
to eric erickson russia was an
incredibly generous figure on a personal
level
and again his ability to take complex
conservatives
conservative ideas and distill them down
to their essence and then
inject them into the body politic with a
large dose of humor is responsible for
the rise of the republican party
over the post-reagan era there's a
reason that in 1994 when republicans won
back congress for the first time in
decades
russia was made an honorary member of
congress
russia's view on politics obviously
shaped the direction of the republican
party
sometimes in ways i disagreed with but
his overall conservative viewpoint
never abated russia was willing to fight
the left he was constantly willing to
fight the left with good humor
and so many of us really owe the fact
that there is an alternative media to
rush limbo without the rise of amtalk
radio there would be no fox news without
fox news
there would be no internet media there'd
be no alternative media there would be
no daily wire
there'd be no ben shapiro show all of us
in the conservative media owe the
existence of an alternative media
to the outsized personality and outsized
talent
of rush limbaugh for sure eric erickson
who is friends with him has quite a
beautiful piece on him today
he writes a few weeks or so after
thanksgiving i was sitting on my front
porch with two friends
we were sharing some bourbon and cigars
my phone went up with a message from
rush
he and my wife have variants of the same
type of lung cancer though hers was
caught very early and her treatment has
thus far contained it
but russia knew she had an older iphone
with a touch id and had been chatting me
to upgrade her
he didn't quite understand my wife's
resistance to technology and insisted i
was neglecting my wife by failing to
give her a steady
state of the art phone undeterred he now
wanted me to know he was sending her a
new iphone 12 pro max
because he was convinced if it hadn't
already her chemo is going to screw up
her fingerprints and make unlocking her
phone difficult
it already had been my wife now has a
better iphone than i do thanks to rush
this is the sort of guy rush was as eric
erickson in the midst of his own far
more serious battle with cancer
he was insistent my wife have a better
phone i was not alone in benefiting from
his generosity he was generous with
advice
and with iphones and god help you if you
offered to buy lunch at a restaurant
you'd inevitably wind up
grieving the white staff who knew rush
was the best tipper in in the restaurant
the erickson household has several
generations of iphones that showed up
thanks to rush
we at one point would race each other to
buy the phone and then emails to claim
victory then he started letting other
people order for him and it wasn't a
fair fight anymore
sometimes even as we disagreed on
politics we would have lengthy email
chains about articles from ours
technical or what apple was doing
eric erickson writes back in 2010 as
herman cain ran for president cox media
group offered me herman cain's job
i was running red state and also on cnn
constantly i really didn't think i
wanted to take on three hours of daily
radio had zero experience wasn't sure
about it at the time
rush ironically had been the one to talk
me into going to cnn instead of fox
sean hannity got me a meeting at fox but
rush that i needed to beep up my
missionary skills and going to cnn where
everyone would be trying to kill me
would help me and besides even cnn
viewers needed to hear the truth
i did it and now a few years later rush
insisted he never talked to me again if
i didn't get on the radio and so i did
a few years later he was telling roger
ailes he should steal me from cnn for
fox
a decade later i'm now doing five hours
of radio a day
much of my career i owe to rush and his
guidance
the fact is that you know as erickson
says rush was a quiet soul he loved
football games and golf
erickson says when i was a teenager
making the obligatory visits to college
with my dad we stumbled on russia's
program while driving through alabama
my dad was searching for paul harvey we
developed a shared affection for rush
and even when we couldn't talk about
other things we could talk about things
russia said
on air i'd stay up late at night and
watch russia's tv show which roger ailes
produced
the day my parents finally stopped
suggesting i should probably hold on to
my law license was the day i filled in
for rush for the first time
now here's the reality so many of us
were shaped by rush my father
is fond of saying that when the history
of the 20th century is written rush
limbaugh's name
will be a prominent name featured
because without rush there is no modern
conservative movement as i said there is
no alternative media
all of us in alternative media owe an
enormous debt of gratitude to rush
and it is worth noting that the way that
the left is responding upon his death is
perfectly predictable
and perfectly disgusting the left is
celebrating rush limbaugh's death today
which is something that i'm sure russ
would have taken with his typical good
humor
and also would have fully expected given
the amount of hatred he received simply
for receiving a presidential medal of
honor
at the state of the union address
if you look at some of the tweets that
are emanating from mainstream sources
they are astonishing one scott shapiro a
professor at yale law school
writes today i wouldn't say i was happy
that rush limbaugh died it's more like
euphoria
twitter trended rush limbaugh along with
the tags
good riddance and wrought in hell
rest in peace rest in peace was replayed
was replaced on twitter with rest in
piss i kid you not
this is the left the sensorious
authoritarian left that hates anybody
who descends
unless you believe this was just about
rush limbaugh it's not if any prominent
conservative
were to die without having embraced
democratic agenda items that person
would be treated exactly the same as
rush and rush knew it
well the right owes much of its modern
creation to rush
so does the modern left which decided
that in response to the rise of russia
they would create an entire censorious
culture
dedicated to taking people off the air
ruining their lives and destroying their
careers
media matters would not exist without
rush
all the folks on the left who spend
their days at the new york times
editorial meetings deciding who to
cancel
they would not exist without rush
because rush awakened in the left
a recognition that if the right was
actually heard
that if the arguments of conservatives
were actually heard they might win and
this
scared the living hell out of them it
scared the absolute living hell
out of them the the tweets that we are
seeing today are
frankly disgusting and naturally all the
people who are issuing these tweets
think that they are the virtuous
over at dead spin a left-wing news
outlet they headline quote
rush limbaugh dead at 70 spewed racist
filth from every pulpit including
including espn's
they tweeted noted fear-monger rush
limbaugh died wednesday he was 70 and an
a-hole
jahada ali of cnn writes for the
washington post sometimes he wrote if
limbaugh spoke about white people and
conservatives the way he did about the
rest of us
his death would be viewed as the end of
an extremist who inspired and promoted
intolerance and hate
across a large part of the country
instead he's a gop hero tells you
everything
charlotte climber who also works for
a wide variety of progressive groups
and writes for mainstream media all the
time right rush limbaugh was a coward
and white supremacist
he was in service to his own greed
prejudice and hypocrisy and that is how
history
will remember him and these are the
this is the best less the left has to
offer this is what the left
believes the left fully believes that
they are so
morally superior that the death of
somebody who disagrees
is worth celebrating dancing on graves
is what they do this is all connected to
a deeper belief
on the left that everybody who disagrees
ought to be censored because after all
if those people get to speak they might
end up like rush limbaugh remember
that the push right now to suggest that
all right wing views
are in essence incitement that didn't
start now that started with rush
limbaugh
when the left decided that rush was
responsible for the oklahoma city
bombing
because he was conservative that was
just
the latest iteration and now we see the
outgrowth of the pernicious
authoritarian leftism
as it takes over the auspices of many of
our major institutions
well if russia limbo's life is to mean
anything it should be
meaningful for all the people he
inspired it should also
remind us that when you fight back you
can win because rush started with
nothing rush started as a scout in the
kansas city royals organization
he started on local am talk radio he
became one of the wealthier men in
america
and a person millions of people listen
to every single day
the possibilities in america are endless
they will remain endless so long as we
take
in serious consideration russia's view
about free markets and free individuals
and we should also remember that the
people who oppose rush they generally
oppose you
they would feel the same way about
anybody on the right who's prominent
dying today as they feel about rush
limbaugh they would celebrate they're
not going to pretend
the rush limbaugh is a fellow american
to them rush is an enemy
so long as they believe that there will
not be unity there will not be unity
the sad
the sort of sad nature of the
polarization of the american public did
not start with rush
the left tries to say it's russia it is
not it is that any time
the leftist monopoly is broken that
person must be castigated and destroyed
and so what you're going to see today
from the mainstream media is them taking
all of the things that rush said that
were worst and taking them out of
context and blowing them out of
proportion
and saying this represents rush limbaugh
you can do this with literally any human
being on planet earth
we all live lives in which we say many
words and many things we regret
the reality is the lasting memory of
rush is going to be
of a gentleman and a person who
laughed with us and at politics and a
person
who tried to share values of
individualism with millions and millions
of americans
and that's a hell of a legacy it really
is
again the creation of the alternative
media it would not exist without rush
limbaugh
the the the woke left's attempts to shut
down debate didn't start today
started yesterday and their hatred for
rush is hatred for you
and we should keep that in mind as we
move forward into the supposed era of
new unity
because there can't be unity until
people on the left realize that rush
limbaugh wasn't their enemy he was just
their political opponent
there is a difference